so right here this is your room Wow yes
it's so empty more like a guy out in the
guest room and how much is this a nice
seven fifty nine seven hundred and fifty
nine dollars wow that's incredibly
expensive and what's that thing there
that is actually the jacuzzi tub in the
middle of the lounge it is in the lounge
Wow because I'm the rooms they took away
all the interior walls but without
sounding stupid these are car designers
correct they are car design now they've
put in jacuzzis in the middle of suite
last time I checked a living room was
for sitting if not taking a bath
how much do these things cost the
jacuzzi tub itself is about twenty
thousand knives if you don't take baths
ah this is crazy who wanted all these
specially design that is their own arias
that's as Eddie yes this is crazy oh
[ __ ] the sports car inspired furniture
looks cheap and isn't even functional
it's different than anything else
different from a nice hotel room I don't
know about that hoo nothin want to sit
here and sort of watch the television
and watch the television it works though
the sheets how can also wrinkle when
having except in there why is that we do
them in house we say we would you mean
you don't do laundry lifestyle means
everything your mouthwash it's like gas
sock is all broken and smashed down
there when someone's left that dirty
ones there the plastic plants
that's outrageous a hundred dollars I
thought you don't know I was just
hanging out sorry to cut your first name
Richard Richard but around here they
kind of call me Papa Papa Papa Papa
we're just battling's all of us are in
there anyway do you normally run four
discs this Baldur's tomorrow okay and
then when music starts coming I turn it
over music the music program women do
tonight says the music there's a band
placement
yes and then we'll probably jam out
later
but what what is the Baja just help me
would you like to see the Butthead I'd
love to see the Baja okay yeah this is
where you run the reception from the
Baja yeah Wow this is the Baja this is
where me and Trudy hang out get up now
what is that smell we've got incense
they're right here incense is a strong
[ __ ] incense here Jesus yeah but that
doesn't smell like the smell of just
smell yet herbs it's a medicinal herb I
love house especially the freshness of
it
you can use it for cooking if you want
to do a really nice fettuccine okay
what's it like this it yeah it's like a
basil wow it has a nice smell to it
[ __ ] me that's definitely not basil is
this cannabis yes
so we smoke pot that's why I could smell
the minute I came in here yeah would you
want me to do is this the you here yes I
use medicinal herb every pay period
there is a problem with the checks every
paper there's a problem of the check and
a lot I don't know what the problem is
on but I know it's the same chippy and
you get to know about it first all you
have to go ask him for your salary I
always ask for it that's absolutely
wrong and the reason is he's lying no no
no he's not lying I would rather have
them wait than write a check that's
going to bounce because I don't how
about telling him it's not gonna be
ready rather than having to ask like son
skivvy cap in hand please sir now get
paid
anybody else have to wait how long
Barbara I had to wait five weeks that's
of what I had to wait five weeks before
I got a paycheck
five weeks guys you come in and you work
your ass off the least these two guys
can do is pay your [ __ ] salary on
time I don't have a secretary Gordon I'm
sorry I'm trying to communicate with
brides I'm trying to send out things I
have to have peaceful time in order to
do my work are you always this pathetic
I am NOT pathetic well when are you
gonna stand up and start showing some
respect for your team and start growing
a pair to sort of understand the mess
you're in I understand the mess we're in
crime fighting for the team you dug the
[ __ ] hole yes
I'm put a minute so there [ __ ] they
don't have to work here
Oh mind me you know the bottom line how
dare you know they don't have to work
how dare you how [ __ ] dare you
they don't have to work here oh my god
I get disrespectful disgusting man
they don't have to work here I don't
think you realize how [ __ ] lucky you
are I don't know how you execute all
that Japanese food on that menu when
you're not trained doesn't make sense
there's not a lot of people in star pool
that like our sushi it's a little bit
different from what other places and
start will have
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Sukie ruins our kitchen the way she
wants to it's always it takes too long
in between tickets but there was really
nothing I could do about it
this food is taking way too long I've
been waiting over an hour for raw fish
oh my god I can't take this anymore
Damon I know it up there my god
does the city usually take this long yes
what is this one Las Vegas all my girls
she's an asparagus and it's deep-fried
and comes with a jalapenos fight salmon
with cream cheese disgusting a strange
combination wait wait doesn't work for
me that one Amy it's just greasy get
this out of the way as quick as possible
okay thank you you're welcome
my first impressions of the food here is
that it's as bad as the rooms in order
french bread as an app all right is that
their sports bar or these TV screens one
of those microwaves
how many microwaves if he goes for here
in one in there at five there's one in
there on two chefs two chefs oh my god
turn that's just junk everywhere well
this is cooking staff trust me I know
what cooking supper this is no that's
okay how does this kitchen function give
me a little tour it's very challenging
very very challenging well sign there
that's a burger get on heating up oh boy
yeah you're boiling a burger I'm just
heating it back up we say he's me back
up why are you cooking it from fresh we
make them another time this is what we
got here we don't a boy burger are you
where the burgers are boiled
no to think a customer would want a
burger boiled in water they seem to like
a flat $23 dreadful tough that's fine
July clam I love lamb
tough as any bullet open perhaps a
little rare a little tough
what is going on no you haven't got much
hotel experience but isn't this your
forte restaurants yes
bloody hell I'm finished with that thank
you I mean dreadful absolutely tell him
it's that lamb frozen but my own comes
frozen then we thought for us you find
out where it's from yes
lamb lollipops no go so far nothing of
taste it has even a remote connection to
the area nothing local nothing authentic
nothing New Mexico New Zealand New
Zealand lamb that part right that parts
right our chicken is piccata is
nontraditional thank you for visiting us
here but son de Mesilla my name is
Callie I'm gonna do just a little music
for you this afternoon
Little Rock number from share
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]